hey there if you've heard of kigo KH
Academy's AI powered tutor and teaching
assistant you probably know about how
it's been developed to help students
solve math problems without giving away
the answer strengthen arguments through
debate or break down complex science
Concepts now we're proud to present our
latest conmigo feature academic essay
feedback this new feature provides
immediate highquality feedback on essays
to help students become more skilled and
confident writers let me show you how it
works to get started all a student needs
to do is submit their essay draft along
with some details about the assignment
click submit and then kigo gets to work
generating both positive and
constructive feedback at the students
grade level you can see that unlike
other writing tools kigo provides more
than just spelling or mechanics feedback
it offers insights into everything from
essay structure and organization to how
well arguments are supported even down
to style and tone students can view the
feedback ask for clarifications or
examples make revisions
and then request more reviews it's like
having a personal writing coach at their
fingertips teachers who found themselves
struggling to regularly provide timely
personalized feedback on hundreds of
essays can now ensure that their
students get immediate quality feedback
on their first drafts without kigo ever
doing the writing for them and like all
other kigo activities the student
experience is moderated for safety and
teachers can view a record of the
students interactions including initial
and revised drafts in their chat history
history to learn more about how to get
access to kigo or bring it to your
school or District visit con academy.org
or click the link in the video
description
below